okay so let's talk about Brett Kavanaugh
a little bit we have this hamstrung and
limited FBI investigation into Donald
Trump's Supreme Court nominee Brett
Cavanaugh that continues Brett Kavanaugh
continues to prove why he is totally
unfit to serve on the Supreme Court and
realistically should be charged with
perjury and now we can add to that
potentially witness tampering if you've
not been following this story it is
stunning
Brett Kavanaugh has been caught in yet
another lie
this one actually bigger than some of
the others and Cavanaugh appears to have
at least potentially tampered with a
witness to the potential crimes that he
committed witness tampering is a crime
and we're gonna dig into that in a
second so let me set it up for you you
might remember that during the hearing
last week with Brett Kavanaugh and his
first of many sexual assault accusers
Christine Blasi Ford Kavanaugh was asked
under oath when was the first time that
he heard about the allegations by dr.
Ford and right after that he was asked
when was the first time that he heard
about the allegations made by Deborah
Ramirez who was a college classmate dr.
Ford a high school classmate Deborah
Ramirez a college classmate he was asked
the question by senator Orrin Hatch
Cavanaugh's answer seemed to be pretty
clear let me remind you what that was
when was the first time that the ranking
member of her staff asked you about
these allegations
today when did you first hear of mr.
Ramirez's allegations against you in the
last in the period since then in The New
Yorker story so the claim is very clear
from Beckett Brett Kavanaugh he first
caught wind the first time he ever heard
that a woman named Deborah Ramirez was
making the allegation that he Cavanaugh
sexually assaulted her was when he read
it in The New Yorker piece by Ronan
Farrow and Jane Mayer after
Ford's allegations unfortunately there
is now direct and specific evidence to
the contrary that suggests that not only
did Brett Kavanaugh know about Deborah
Ramirez his allegations against them
well before he read about them in The
New Yorker he was actually proactively
engaged in planning out how to refute
her allegations Carrie Bertram and Karen
Yaris savage are both friends or I guess
we could say at least used to be friends
or acquaintances of Brett Cavanaugh's
Bertram has come forward and said she
has text messages detailing that Brett
Kavanaugh was speaking with former Yale
classmates remember Christine Blasi Ford
was a high school classmate the Deborah
Ramirez allegations she's a Yale
classmate they relate to Cavanaugh's
alleged actions when he was at Yale that
Brett Kavanaugh was talking to
classmates asking them to get involved
to go on record refuting the allegations
he knew stemmed from his former
classmate Deborah Ramirez asking for
people to contact Deborah Ramirez to try
to influence what it is that she plans
to say all before September 23rd which
was the date of that New Yorker article
about Deborah Ramirez this is a direct
and and bold-faced lie unless time goes
backwards unless Brett Kavanaugh has a
time machine how can you be both working
to refute claims of Deborah Ramirez and
claim that you were not aware of those
claims until you read about them in The
New Yorker on September 23rd so yet
another apparent lie and this one might
also actually be criminal witness
tampering it's not clear it's going to
depend on the specifics and on the facts
it might be witness tampering but in
either case it's completely
inappropriate and once again if you are
a nominee to the Supreme Court you
should not be content contacting
potential witnesses against you we heard
from Fordham Law Professor Jed Sugarman
who says that this is witness tampering
others say it's not so clear but this is
not good for Brett Kavanaugh and even
worse is that Bertram Kari Bertram the
former friend and classmate of Brett
Kavanaugh she claims
that the FBI isn't even getting back to
her about this she claims that she went
to the FBI she knows what's going on
with Cavanaugh she knows there's an
investigation going on I'll be it a very
hamstrung one she goes to the FBI and
says hey Brett Cavanaugh said this
during the hearing I have text message
evidence that that was a lie talk to me
and as of at least a few hours ago she
says that the FBI hasn't even followed
up set a spokesman for Senator Chuck
Grassley who's running this entire
circus of an investigation of a
confirmation hearing claims that the
texts text messages are a political ploy
by Democrats how are text messages that
Brett Kavanaugh is party to a ploy by
Democrats the Democrats trick Cavanaugh
into text messaging people it doesn't
make any sense and and what we have
ultimately here is significant hypocrisy
imagine for a second if a Barack Obama
Supreme Court pick had this going on
Republicans would be calling for prison
time never mind considering whether or
not they should make a rush appointment
for life to the highest court in the
land this is an issue on which
Republicans and Democrats are simply
different on this program when
Republicans and Democrats are
effectively the same I tell you that
when Republicans and Democrats are
different I tell you that Anthony Weiner
was accused of a sexual impropriety he
is totally gone from politics I don't
know of any Democrats that were
defending what Anthony Weiner did Al
Franken former Minnesota senator Franken
did like 1% of what Brett Kavanaugh is
accused of here he resigned within days
with Democrats saying that he should
resign meanwhile allegation after lie
after distortion after allegation from
Brett Kavanaugh and what do Republicans
do they simply continue trying to push
through his nomination even more quickly
the similarities between that and the
relationship of the Republican Party to
Cavanaugh and how it compares to Trump
very very similar unhinged both erratic
both liars both tampering with witnesses
both accused of serial sexual assault
maybe that's why Trump is standing
behind Brett Kavanaugh but I actually
think that there's more to it I think we
actually are increasingly figuring out
what the real story is about why Trump
will not abandon Brett Kavanaugh I'm
going to talk to you about that after
the break
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and boy do we have a good
one for you today today's show was made
possible in part by scion games
and their new game for phone and tablet
called antidote which is an award
winning strategy game it's all about
using vaccines to defend the human body
from bacteria and viruses it's fast
paced the graphics are amazing the game
has actually been commended by the World
Health Organization because it has a
mission to fight back against anti
vaccine misinformation so the game is
educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off deadly diseases and don't
forget to search for scion games on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram if you're
watching this on youtube I've put the
links under the video